Those 3 Kageketsu became undead and were still alive.
Are you serious about being immortal? Please give me a break. I don't
think they'll attack you. I'm sorry for keeping
quiet until now. Ah,
by the way, it's Sanei Ketsu.  I was crying when I heard the song. No, I'm
not crying.
This is the
Mist of Lost. Yes, it's my grandfather's magic. It's a
magic located above the Lost Alley that protects the Academy. I've heard rumors about it, but this is the first time I've seen it.  Isn't it the
highest level of magic? People with a lifespan of only a few years have
learned this and are using it.
Is it serious? I mean, it's like, ``I'm going to erase my existence in battle.'' I'm going to
make a loophole now, so
wait.  It's
like gas. If
this word is gas, then this is what I put here. Let's
go.
[Music]
Ah.